hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
today I want to talk about is the go
charting platform uh for using order
flows Trader and you know the nice thing
about the gold charting platform is it's
web based so you know if you're on a Mac
or you know you're on the go and you
want to watch the market from your phone
you can actually do that with the go
charting platform and
uh you know I posted a video earlier in
the week I did a very long presentation
over the weekend on go charting and you
know I got a lot of questions about how
to set up the chart
um you know how to get it to look like
uh what you're looking at right here and
I just want to take you sort of through
the steps it's very easy to set up you
don't really need my template or
anything like that but um you know I'll
just take you through the through the
whole setup
um very quick so let me just take off
the order close Trader here and I'm
going to change this from a footprint
chart or they call it cluster chart on
go charting I'm going to just start with
the basic Candlestick chart and I'm also
going to also take off uh This Bar
statistics panel
um just so you know really starting from
scratch okay so if you're starting from
you know just the basic footprint chart
or sorry basic Candlestick chart and you
want to get the footprint chart this is
what you do right what you do is first
go to charts Okay click on cluster right
it's alt F if you were to use the
keyboard
that will give you the footprint that's
the basic footprint right with the uh
you know the point of control the
volumes on the bid the volume's on the
offer now what you got to do is you go
into layers really quick and again if it
doesn't look like this you know you may
need to adjust it say you have you know
you could some people like to look at
just uh you know sort of one
thing of numbers right I prefer two so
the cluster is going to be it's from
single you change it to double all right
and then on the
left side of the bar right the left
cluster you're going to set that to cell
volume you have a lot of choices in here
um there's trades by trades sell trades
Etc use the cell volume that's the
actual amount of volume that's traded on
the bid side and then for the right
cluster
you're going to want to make it the buy
volume okay because that's the amount of
volume traded on the offer side right
and it does get a little confusing for
people say why is that the buy volume if
if that's where sellers are well it's
passive sellers but what you have is the
aggressive buyers right that's why if it
trades on the
right hand side
it's aggressive buyers buying from
passive sellers right remember it's a
two-way auction so for every buyer
there's a seller right you can't have a
trade unless there's somebody buys it
from someone or someone you know sells
it to another person
now
one thing that I like to do I like black
as my text color so you know you're
going to want to say where it says text
right here
you can just click on that and you know
set it to Black okay same otherwise you
know if you have gray some some guys you
know like to have different colors for
you know their text I know some people
have
um
you know some Vision form of vision
impairment you know as we get older you
know our eyesight starts to go a bit but
um that's what you want to I like to
keep it black on a white background I
know some people like to use a black
chart with you know white text or the
opposite but again to each their own now
the imbalances okay make sure you have
it enabled I like to have the imbalances
colored blue for a buying imbalance and
red for a selling imbalance okay that's
me
um you know some people
don't want to have those color schemes
Etc but you know if there's a buying of
balance I know that that's aggressive
buying at a level I want to have that
highlighted to me okay and that's where
um you know having the colors
highlighted will you know
give you a big advantage in my opinion
so make sure you have that uh box
checked now
there is another box here which says
imbalance color okay if you were to
click on that and change the color to I
don't know
um you know in this case I'll make it
orange okay what that will show you
is it will also highlight
that price level on the bid or the offer
where there is an imbalance also okay so
you know maybe you want uh you know an
extra
whack over the head saying hey you know
what there's an imbalance here you can
do that I you know I don't think you
really need that but again you know some
people you may find that useful
um in your trading you know because
maybe depending on where the imbalance
appears in the bar is going to be
important to you as well now they have
another Choice here show support and
resistance zones if you click on that
right it's going to show you where the
Stacked imbalances are right this is a
stacked buying and balance here I think
earlier we had a stack selling a balance
right here okay
now for that stacked imbalance you could
set the number of imbalances you want to
see
in there
three I believe is the default but again
you know you can set it to four you can
set it to two even right and you're
going to get a bit more right here's two
here here's two here and if it isn't
traded into in the next bar so it will
draw it out all right it'll draw this
zone out like that and some people like
to use that as a support and resistance
level now really important what level
are you going to use for your imbalance
okay I like to use four to one some
people like to use three to one some
people like to use five to one four to
one to me is is good you know meaning I
have four times as many aggressive
sellers than passive you know aggressive
Traders and passive traders meaning you
know for example here right you see 16
against 109 that is greater in this
two-way auction
um you have more aggressive buying by a
ratio of at least four to one
on the offer here okay so that that's uh
what it is so let me just turn off this
uh
amounts now point of control
okay
you
there there
there's sort of two settings on this
point of control okay and
the first one point of control is
showing you
sort of the
price level in the bar let me turn off
this other one volume Point control the
the price is in the bar either on the
bid side or the offer side it has the
most volume so it's showing here
um
oh let's start here right on this bar
right here in the middle it's got both
the bid and the offer the same price
it's the highest volume on the bid side
is at this price the highest volume on
the offer is at this price and it's the
same price level most of the time that's
going to be the same however there's
going to be sometimes where it is a
little bit uh lopsided right you can see
here this is the price level with the
most volume on the mid side this is the
price level with the most volume on the
offer side so it's two different levels
and
you know I'm going to make a video about
this particular
um
what do you want to call it set up in a
way
um on how you can take advantage of that
but for now you know if you want the
traditional point of control it's going
to be this volume point of control okay
so I'll take off this POC so as the
volume point of control it's green color
all right and you can see it appearing
in each bar right now this is just the
one level
in the bar with the most volume okay now
you could extend it out right the sort
of the naked or virgin point of control
which to me is a very useful tool
um they've already had this one in go
charting
you know as sort of one of their their
default settings and it's nice to see
these bars
um where the next bar doesn't come back
in and trade to that point of control
okay and you know if you want to see
where the previous bars point of control
was you know you can click on previous
point of control marker and it's
important to know that sometimes I mean
I think you can see it pretty easily
without you having to use this but you
know on a market that's moving up
generally you're going to see the next
bar so it'll come back down and test
that point of control
okay just as if the market was going
down it'd be testing it in the reverse
side and oftentimes you can see where it
just literally comes right down you know
to the tick oftentimes right
you know here's gets passed it by two
ticks
um comes right down within one tick here
and again it's one of those things where
you know it's a nice visual thing but
again
there's a lot of tools on this is a very
robust uh charting platform and you
don't necessarily need to put everything
all up on your screen at once because
ultimately it may confuse you okay
so these are the basic sort of settings
right that I'm going to use on a cluster
chart
now to add the order flows Trader
add-on right
um you're going to go to studies
up here and you're going to click on
order flow
you're gonna find order flows Trader in
the menu here
you just click on that okay now you've
added the order flows Trader and you can
go through and decide which parts of the
order closed Trader you want to use so
you're gonna minimize the cluster
settings and go to order flows Trader
and you can see we have quite a few
we've got exhaustion prints imbalance
reversal the ratios
a slingshot point of control Market
weakness sequencing Market sweep
Prominent Point controls zero prints
inverse imbalance multiple imbalances
buying and selling tails and thin prints
now again it's up to you to decide which
ones you want to use
um for e-minis
you know I would recommend you know you
can turn on exhaustion prints
um you can even have well you actually
could have most of these on there if I
were to turn them all on okay they're
not all going to fire at the same time
but you know if you want you can turn
these all on I don't necessarily think
you really need to the way I advocate
trading with order flow since it's a lot
of information
um you don't want to sort of run into
areas where you have too much
information okay
you want to sort of focus on the things
that resonate with you that you can
understand right so for example
okay uh was it or here sequencing okay
bullish is bullish and bearish
sequencing let's talk about this a bit
it's right here this is bullish
sequencing this is bearish sequencing
right you got this little move down a
little move up and it's highlighting on
the bar where it's appearing here right
that's this sort of magenta area that's
this
red area on the red down candle
um you know another thing that I like to
use I was talking about it yesterday in
a in a separate video was the Prominent
Point it controls right this is a
bullish Prominent Point of control right
here Market had a nice move up
um here's a bearish one but we traded uh
right through it you know right away so
you know there's a lot of tools right
now you can get the order flows Trader
add-on for go charting for free until
the end of August okay and
you know after that it's going to become
a a paid add-on but you know it's the
nice thing is it does right now you know
it it works with every all the different
contracts so you know
that's the uh you know here that's
e-minis right you go you know micro
NASDAQ if you want mnq uh here we go
make sure I got September on here now
again you know mnq is uh
bigger contract and you can see in here
right all the different things now on a
different market right like M and Q
maybe you don't want to probably use
sequencing or Market sweeps you're going
to sort of refine what you're looking at
right for mnq I like to use
um I don't let me just clean this up I'm
buying selling Tails
um I don't need multiple imbalances zero
prints I don't need Prominent Point of
controls Market weakness slingshot order
flows ratio imbalance reversal and uh
inverse imbalances okay
and again you know some other contracts
even if you were into ETFs right spy
it's py
there you go here's spy right QQQ
okay
um
Euros I mean FX 4X uh
you know
eurocad or something
I'm just choosing one at random right
you can see it's gonna take sometimes to
get the data there you go first time you
launch the contract
um it can take a while now one other
thing I do want to add really quick let
me just go back to the euro well the
Euro future 6E
um the bar statistics okay I didn't talk
about that but those are like the Delta
you know the volume the max Delta the
Min Delta
um you got to go to study
uh or is it here under order flow click
on bar statistic
okay and it's going to be right here now
depending on what you want to look at
again this also has a lot of robust
features in there
um not just this you could go in and set
up what you want to look at let me uh
open this up here you can see there's
all these metrics
for me personally I like to see just the
volume
the Delta the max Delta the Min Delta
the cumulative Delta and Delta
percentage but you know if you want to
see you know other things
um you know
where we are with view app I don't know
what that one works obviously there's so
much of these I haven't even explored
into there all this but you know I like
to look at the information that I'm
familiar with that's going to help my
training I'm sure once I sit down and
sort of go through all these different
ones I'm sure I'll find a few that can
um that can help me you know max volume
whatever that is Max probably the most
very probably I need to open this up a
bit here
whoops
okay you can see there's max volume Min
volumes Etc and
you know for some of you guys you may
find that useful you might not again you
can choose what you want to put on there
now another
uh tool which I haven't really gone into
but it's very useful is the Delta bars
okay so that's basically it's a
Candlestick form of
Delta okay and
let me just minimize this
open this up here and you can see how
you can adjust the colors Etc
um on it and
you can even
run sort of a you know a moving average
I don't get into this right now it's a
more advanced concept but you know you
could
foreign
there's ways you could use you know me I
like to use pattern recognition and
there's certain types of Delta candles
that I like to look at me I've done a
presentation on this years ago I should
refresh that but there are certain
basically what you're looking at with a
Delta candle is
the max Min Delta in the bar as well as
the final Delta where it appeared so for
example here this candle right you got
this little red candle here
okay well obviously every bar the candle
opens at zero in terms of Delta and it
went down to -60 that's why you see this
Wick here right down here
but it only closed at the Delta close at
-18 right so it's negative that's why
you have the small body so you got the
long Wick right right here
and the small body okay now
what um you know one of the unique
things about
go charting right is
they will the software you can have the
software draw a line where you have this
bar in Delta Divergence right and that's
important
so I know that this candle right I see
this red area
okay so it's telling me that you know
you got negative Delta on this green
candle just as if you got this red
candle here with positive Delta okay and
there's certain ways to trade that okay
but I'm not going to get into that right
now
um you know look for another video on it
but again you know if you haven't
watched that video I that I did post it
the other day it's a long one it's like
oh it's over it's almost close to two
hours
um but I really go in depth on the go
charting platform and it's a great way
to get started with order flow
um you know at a low price right and
especially if you're interested in the
order of those Trader software it's a
great way to get introduced to it
because I said right now it's available
for free until the end of August of 2023
um after which it become a paid add-on
but again not at an overly expensive
price
and you know it works on futures
Forex crypto you know
crypto oh what do we got here BTC
USD
right this is a one minute chart
remember yesterday we had that uh
big dump
and crypto so here it's guys you know
it's getting Gathering all the
statistics here for me so if I take a
little while for it to come up here but
that's pretty quick right
so you can see right this it's all it's
still coming in still filling in the
data but right now this is uh where are
we here
it is uh Friday morning about 10 20.
all right so this is a 15 minute chart
let me just go to
sort of
shorter chart and I mean it looks like
hey there's no footprint here what you
have to do is you have to expand it
right
and when you're dealing with crypto
right your settings for the footprints
all right this is auto mode for crypto
so you can see the footprint here all
right so you can see
um certain things happening developing
in the order flow
on your chart right and you know maybe
you don't want to use the
Delta
bars all right so you just close it down
maybe you don't want to use the bar
statistics for crypto you just delete it
right to add it back you just go under
studies right if you want the bar
statistics back go to
our statistics right if you want the
Delta bars back you just go to Delta
bars okay so you know that's the gold
charting that's a very very quick and
and short explanation of the go charting
platform and again
um you know I got some links down in the
chat or not the chat but in the comments
section if you're interested in it
um
you know right now for the Futures data
they do have a a special discount price
running
where you can get it for just ten
dollars a month as opposed to Thirty or
ten dollars for the first month but then
after the first month it will go back up
to uh
35 but again you know that's that's a
drop in the bucket compared to what
you'd be paying for
data from any other provider and again
you know if you're interested in testing
out the order flows Trader software
um it's you know available for free on
the go charting platform until the end
of uh this month August end of August so
thanks everyone and I'll see you guys on
the next video bye-bye foreign